hey everybody and welcome back to morals
for the very final time today before I
get into the POV video on Christmas Eve
and basically what are we doing today is
pretty much everything that still needs
to be done so there are a lot of things
and I can't really name them all at once
but it's just generally finishing the
scenery around the ride doing lots of
foliage and work work doing all these
smaller path things which I haven't
really done so far like making these
planters and generally dressing up the
area around the rind because so far we
just have to ride the station and a bit
around that but there's no real
experience for the guests yet so I kind
of want to deliver on that as well theme
the queue a little bit and then there
are some wee little odds and ends like
the Christmas tree which might happen at
some point in this episode the lake pier
thing which I just sort of decided to do
on a whim because there wasn't much else
there and finishing everything off with
a weenie pretty much which is gonna be a
huts that sits on top of a mountain I
know it sounds very lame but that's
something which hopefully it should be a
pretty good way to close this series and
get to the very final video and also
that's of course I'll return to your
regularly scheduled planet coaster
videos but this is basically almost the
last of this sort of special Christmas
week here now one of the one of the
first things that I wanna quickly
comment on this actually then I found
this way well it's very simple really
but I found this way to make like
hanging Christmas lights one of the
things which always kind of bugged me
about the lights which they added into
the game no matter how good they are
because I am very happy that these have
been added into the game but what kind
of bugged me about them is that they're
made to be placed on buildings they're
made to be hung from buildings and on
the side of like roof trims and things
like that which is beautiful it's it's a
very Christmassy thought but it's not
the kind of thing that you can hang
around in the sense that many Christmas
decorations are just kind of strings of
lights and strings of flags and stuff
like that just decorations that sort of
are placed on top of what is normally
there so it's things like these like
these strings of lights which I decided
to put a meter in the lanterns which I
wanted to focus on things that
you know the entire coaster would still
look good if you take away the Christmas
decorations like the Christmas
decorations or in anything that
substantially makes the ride they just
sort of has a feel like additions that
were just sort of thrown in there for
the Christmas season which is kind of
why I'm you know wanted to hang these
things from lanterns and put them next
to trims on buildings instead of making
everything revolve around them so that
was us that very quick thing and I'll be
recycling a lot of those things as well
so here I'm just taking the same strings
I've got like three strings of Lights at
this point like a long a short and a
medium one and that should hopefully be
just about good enough to have the few
strips now what I have here in there and
on this side pretty much I did the same
a couple of lanterns few lights in
between I'm not sure like how happy I am
with this side I originally thought it
might be really cool to have a small
snack bar or something like that on this
side there just isn't enough time to do
that so it's really just some basic
standard kind of detailing bunch of
rocks and foliage here and then the path
elements and I'm not too sure how much I
do like that but at least it gives a
finished sense to the area and I
definitely didn't want to make anything
that draws attention to itself because
for this entire area of the station is
the only thing that's gonna want to draw
attention so I didn't want to put
anything in there that would block the
line of sites or be something more
interesting to look at now at this point
we're moving toward the place where I'll
be adding a pier in a little bit but not
quite yet I first actually wanted to get
into more decorations of places so at
this point I'm just very quickly
finishing off the shrubs here and there
and then I wanted to get into more
lighting and detailing so what I'm doing
over here is adding a couple of lights
next to these posts that I already had
because I think I mentioned this in the
last episode I had those separate light
posts which I need for the spotlights
and then I also had real light posts on
the side of that which didn't make a lot
of sense so instead I'm now using the
spotlight posters regular light post as
well and the tunnel over here which is
absolutely overcrowded at this point it
should be much better in the future
I don't know why it was this bad at this
point but usually it's not this crowded
but anyway this tunnel needed a couple
of lights so I made a quick iron work
lights kind of thing to copy-paste
around there and then I also wanted to
have another kind of lights that I could
use on the side that's a little bit
smaller so there's yet another unique
lights I wanted to make a couple extra
small ones for the side there and then
for the QI making yet another one so
that every area has its own kind of
unique lights and things like that I've
talked about this times and times before
but for me adding these little
differences in details is super
important not reusing the fence like the
same fence all over the park not reusing
the same benches and the same lights all
over the park for me is a super
important thing like even in a small
space it adds a lot more character to
whatever you're making if you were
switching up the items which you're
using it just takes away all the
atmosphere if you see the same fence
around the plaza all over like the
entire area it's just much more fun to
have all of these different types which
is why I make that abundance of
different lights over there it wasn't
too much work though most of them just
take the template of a light switch I
built and just kind of add or subtract
some things to it or had some things to
add or subtract from it and here I also
wanted to finish the building which I
have for the q''-word just 6x4 a little
bit this is actually a bit button
Octonauts and after I am sorry about the
pronunciation for all of you non Dutch
people but it's it's a bit like it since
it also has that key where it really
winds around and has a couple of places
where it actually snakes what you do see
more often but I I wanted to have this
mix of having it snake somewhere then or
at least having the path kind of flow
through a landscape then having a small
building right snakes and then having it
flow through a landscape again so that
you can actually make the most out of
the area because there's quite a neat
area
like having a coaster overhead and
having the lake and some mountains on
the sides it felt like a too nice area
to just put the queue in a small space
and put buildings around it and instead
I wanted to make sure that you actually
see the entire surroundings of the queue
that's why I wanted to make it as open
as I really could here
besides queues are super important
they're arguably one of the most
important things in a theme park because
Annette any busy day that you're gonna
get your most guests most guests are
also gonna spend most of that time
inside a queue so you better make them
part of the experience which is really
the most important thing about queues so
with that almost out of the way I just
wanted to add all of the railings in
this building actually use some
different railings in here as well I
felt it would become a bit too dense and
boring if I use that same balustrade all
over the place so I decided to switch it
up a bit with these very small unique
posts which I had on the other side of
the station as well and that more or
less finishes that building only thing
that I still wanted to add at this point
are some lanterns and a few planters or
hanging blonde baskets stuff like that
to dress it up a little bit make it a
bit more cozy but it's it's really the
placement of this building which I felt
is most important you'll definitely see
in the final video how it's gonna work
out exactly but I just felt like it
would be a beautiful thing to have this
very small pond with this this.q
building next to it the coaster on the
other side and then in the distance
having all of the hills might not make
too much sense right now but there are
some pretty cool and interesting sight
lines that I wanted to make use of with
this queue now something which well
turned out to be like the big
time-consuming thing and actually a
pretty large part of this video is just
finishing up all of the foliage and all
of the rook work in this park which I
was kind of getting comfortable with at
this point like I've already done a
couple of smaller areas so there's
already kind of a system as to how I'm
doing it it
really very similar to what I've done to
me on here and what I've basically
always been doing start with the rocks
first kind of lay those out and some
areas especially where you feel like
they would start to clutter so at the
bottom of these hills and especially in
these little valleys but also all of
these books on top of these hills make
it look a bit more interesting it
doesn't all have to be extremely
realistic and after that get into some
of these smaller shrubs like the green
shrubs that I'm placing over here
I wanted to sink them into the ground
low enough so they would look like they
aren't entirely covered with snow
anymore or at least their bottom is kind
of covered with snow at least I didn't
want them to stand out I just wanted to
use them to add a bit of color to these
areas because obviously with the white
snow and the white snow covered pine
trees there isn't a lot of colors to go
for anymore
so it kind of helps with that and then
the second bush that I'm using a lot
here is again that there's a kind of
Bush which looks a lot like dry cross
but definitely helps to blend everything
together and it's beautiful little piece
of foliage that you can even use as
filler in some places like some of these
places where it's just open snow and
nothing else
ice sometimes it's like they place these
things as if there were a lot of reed
over there something like that now
interestingly I also wanted to keep like
these these terrorists looking rocks
quite open and not placed too many trees
I think a very very easy pitfall to fall
into and definitely one that I've fallen
into a lot as well is the urge to fill
every single open space that you have
with trees like everything that's still
empty feels like it needs to be filled
in with trees sometimes I don't know if
I'm you know how many people would feel
this way but I've definitely seen a lot
of people struggle with this or talk
about this a lot and I think it's
actually really important to just leave
some areas open sometimes just not place
any trees in there maybe fill it up a
little bit with bushes and rocks to make
it not completely empty but at least you
know you don't really notice the forest
if there are only trees basically there
is a Dutch saying which I don't know if
it translates for how into English but
it's like you
see the forest anymore through the trees
and you need like some open space it's
actually still like half the forest
stand out anyway I am massively behind
the video again I am working on the
quick pier over here which is something
that I wasn't really planning to do
beforehand it just kind of felt like
something I did on a whim the reason for
it was kind of that this part of the
ride of the coaster otherwise felt very
disconnected from the rest of the ride
it goes over the lake but there's no
real incentive to go to this part of the
park if there were no path because
there's no ride over here there isn't a
bridge or something over the lake that
would have been stupid anyway basically
it kind of felt like a desperate little
zone that's just completely empty and
we're just the coaster came so I wanted
to connect it a bit and also have a bit
of interaction with the path over here
so he's on it to make this little pier
I'm not sure if I'm really gonna do
anything like connect a boat to it or
something that's something that I will
have to decide in the end but the basic
premise is not really to be a functional
pier but really to to be a part of the
scenery to be part of the layouts and
interact with the coaster a bit more
make this entire scene a bit more
interesting so the coaster pulses very
close by this thing and you have to
mention that you know you don't have to
be able to have some benches some areas
where you can sit on top of this pier
and just have this beautiful place where
you can look at a coaster because
honestly I am I'm that kind of person
and I know a lot of people are like this
as well we're just looking at a coaster
aloneness just amazing and nothing hurts
me more than a coaster which completely
shuts itself off from any and all paths
and is only visible from the coaster
itself unless it's an indoor coaster but
you get the point basically I want to
put it on the showcase as much as I can
here and then the size of the lake I
sort of wanted to detail the lake the
most on the side where you can actually
see it from very up close on the side of
the pier and the other side I just
wanted to put a bunch of simple rocks
bunch of trees and leave it at that so
you can kind of see the level of detail
on the amount of details that I put in
I get lower and lower as you get further
away from the coaster which is
definitely a very very basic tip but
something very important as well to keep
in mind there are too many people who
have seen placing bushes on the other
side of the map then where you actually
see anything which is a waste of Polly's
and a waste of your time so it's
definitely something that I would avoid
and I generally go less detailed as you
go further away from the point where you
actually see everything also to save a
bit of time I saved a blueprint over
here which is something that I
definitely recommend anyone doing if you
have a large space to fill with trees
just place a cup of them make a
blueprint out of it and you can save
yourself a lot of time in the long run
there are so many things which blue
prints are amazing for and at this point
I feel like the ride is really coming
together especially from the lake it has
an almost finished look to it I just had
this unfinished corner which still don't
have any rocks and foliage and then
there's the area with the station but it
doesn't really impact the look at the
right that much this was the first thing
that I wanted to tackle and actually
finish this area over here where again I
wanted to leave some open spaces but not
necessarily because I didn't want to
fill everything with forests but also
because there are some sight lines that
I feel are very important over here that
I wanted to preserve at all costs so the
first one is from the queue just before
you enter the little roof building on
the queue if you look over the lake
there's gonna be this open place where
there aren't any trees blocking the view
and then in the distance you can see
this rock looming up basically the same
kind of goes from the main path as you
approach the station from the park
entrance you'll actually be able to see
this rock kind of loom up in the
distance between the station and the
loop of the coaster so I wanted to keep
that sight line open as well so there
aren't too many trees around there but
it's definitely in a very important
place and it's gonna be much more
important once I add the wingy on top of
it but before that there's still no of
the attending to do so the first thing
that I wanted to do here is work a bit
on the general area for the
which is not too interesting just you
know it's an unfinished area there
aren't any trees or any scenery so I
wanted to fix that but what is
interesting is that this is also where I
built my quick Christmas tree I didn't
want to go over the top
the guests are absolutely going bonkers
for that little part of there but I
didn't want to go over the top for the
Christmas tree I just wanted to have a
few decorations in there but not just
you know populate it too much with all
of these Christmas bells and stuff so
it's quite simple but I didn't want to
use an in-game regular tree and then
that created myself so that there's
still a few of those snow coverings and
at least to give it a bit of a personal
touch I personally do like red
decorations and I don't know why people
even have silver decorations in
Christmas trees it's just too colourless
like what are you even doing so I wanted
to have some colorful decorations in
here generally I'm just switching it up
between two types of the Christmas balls
I don't know what you actually call them
in English and then there's the
Christmas bells and of course the stone
on top and of course some big presence
at the bottom like really huge presents
so that should give any pretty cool
festive kind of atmosphere to this
entire area I suppose there are of
course be other other kind of
decorations you know like these rocks in
the foliage but also barrels any kind of
any kind of thing that you might see
stored around areas like this but it's
the Christmas thing and the Christmas
tree and the Christmas decorations and
of course presents that I feel make it
the most Christmas kind of atmosphere so
that's the most important part I would
say of the detailing here now with that
out of the way all that was still left
to do is foliage but that's boring so
let's skip ahead and go into the very
final thing of this video which is the
hut on top of the hill now I want to say
I wanted to keep this as simple as I
could because I didn't have that much
time left at this point and well I also
just recycled the parts that I made
earlier on and at this point I basically
saved every custom-made modular piece
time
made so I have a pretty solid collection
of different custom Russian pieces at
this point and all I still have to do is
just put these things together in a most
of the kind of sense that actually
wasn't that much work because most of
the work for this building has already
been done upfront in making these custom
pieces so it's very simple Hut's I just
put the roof pieces together that I
already had the only thing that I wanted
to do with this thing that was slightly
more complicated is the onion Tower and
I got so many requests to do this kind
of thing actually considered it right
from the start from episode 1 you've got
like these famous Russian onion and bell
towers with the spiraling collars you
know like you see on many Russian
landmarks and it's something that you
definitely see in some of these more
traditional smaller wooden huts as well
especially in theme parks it's a very
fancy addition I was just very afraid of
making these things since you know
they're onion towers and one of the
hardest things to make if not the
hardest things to make custom when it
comes to spires so in the end I just
decided to go for a very small one that
fits the simple wooden Outback kind of
atmosphere of the build and make it in a
simple way as well just make one outline
and copy that into the shape that I need
and that is basically it and that is
also more or less its for this episode
so I really want to thank you guys for
watching this and I want to thank you
guys for watching this entire series
it's been awesome have a Merry Christmas
and if I don't see you any more
a happy 2017 as well and stay tuned for
the POV video see you later guys
[Music]